[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for listening you're
in for a delightful sexy little treat
today please hit the Subscribe button
don't want to forget that it's deeply
appreciated today on the show is meline
Moon she is a Mythic relationship
magician she's an expert in the language
of the body she's also an author and she
has a podcast called mindbody musing and
so you know she has an immersion coming
up February 9th to 11th in Sedona called
Unbound today was fun and interesting
and informative she uh Taps into sort of
like the shape that you take meaning the
body and like how you present and and
also the energy so at the beginning we
talked about what that looks like what
what what do you mean by the shape of
the body and how you can change that and
how you can tap into that and how you
can be something different this is an
episode if you want to upgrade your
energetic and sexual authenticity
of how you are in the world and how you
are in relationship this is the episode
for you if you've been following me a
while you know that I've been drinking
ag1 all year no matter where I go or
what I do if I'm at the racetrack if I'm
in Europe for six weeks no matter what
I'm drinking ag1 every single morning
when I started drinking ag1 daily what I
noticed was that my gut health improved
I could eat so many different foods
without it bothering me my skin has
gotten better my hair is healthier so
many functions that everybody wants to
get better got better it's so awesome
and I've been bragging about it so much
that my friends and my family have also
started taking it and they love it as
well ag1 is the supplement that I trust
to support my body's daily needs and
that's why we have been partners for so
long if you want to take ownership of
your health it starts with ag1 try ag1
and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 plus five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drink a1.com pretty intense that's drink
a1.com pretty intense check it out
burning man I wish I could have ran into
you but what did you love about it like
being the first time what did you do
maybe like go through like people I
think are fascinated to know like what
is burning really like so you know what
did you get up
to so I was only there for three days
this time because I had something I
needed to be at so one of those days I
was teaching I taught a workshop that I
led people through an experience of
shape shifting and taking different
shapes and I was using animals as well
as taking the shape of Shame and then
taking the shape of Shame meets [__] and
then taking the shape of Shame meets
Wild and then shame meeting tender and
um all of those different pieces had
equivalent like energies that you could
feel in your body like growing Talons
and fangs and like what would it be like
if you had felt your Primal animal body
with your shame human body and you
[__] it like just like this I don't
know it just whole this whole thing
emerged for me when I taught that so
that day it was pretty focused on like I
want to I'm going to teach at Burning
Man which was definitely itely a
challenge for me because I am so
meticulous with my containers who's
coming come on time da da da the minute
I started there was no audio guy there
was no music playing like you know
people I had no way to promote what I
was doing and I very much want to know
that when I teach I teach to a full room
so I had to practice like what if no one
comes up because no one knows or comes
because they don't know about it and
then the audio wasn't working and like
gave me a tiny portable little stereo to
use and I was like nuh-uh so God bless
my boyfriend he ran got somebody who
came and fixed it besides that still a
beautiful experience but I loved the
temple me and my partner had one night
where we were in the temple from 800 pm
to 4:00 a just making prayers and vows
and offerings to each other and
offerings to our loved ones and it was
just this really deep
ceremony and for anyone that hasn't gone
there there's this beautiful Temple
where people leave their prayers and
they They Mourn people who have past and
they leave pictures and offerings all
over this beautiful building and that
was one of my one of my favorite things
besides the art carts and like all the
music that went by and the color and it
was like such a beautiful experience and
I'm fairly obsessed now yeah so so
you'll be back oh yeah oh yeah I right
afterwards I was like okay we got to go
get our tickets for the next year my
partner was like we'll see we'll just
like you know but I was I'm feeling I'm
feeling the like deep burner energy
already from that first one when I went
the first time last year I was like
actually when I was there because it was
a bit hard and it was very like a super
super hot and windy one so it's like
over 100 degrees it was about 20 degrees
warmer at all times last year than this
year and it was like the camper that I
was in like didn't really had only a
generator to produce AC and things
weren't really like thing I could only
run it a couple hours a day and I didn't
have enough gas for it it was hard and
so after a few days I was like I
definitely don't need to do this every
year and then by the end of it when
things kind of fell into place I was
like okay and as I was like after I just
after I left like the next day I'm like
that was so cool I can't wait to go back
again next year so it definitely is such
an interesting in place but I often
describe to people what I think the most
ironic thing about it is that it feels
like such a free place but it's actually
the rules that make it free did you
notice that like did you know like
there's the Ten Commandments like the 10
rules for Burning Man and it's within
those rules that people follow so
closely that they actually have freedom
yeah exactly and it's it is the
containment it is the container that
allows people to fully be on board with
what you're doing there like what are we
doing here we're like returning it feels
like a return it feels like a return and
an appreciation for community at its
core and art like it's so centered
around art and I think that those
perimeters that are in place really give
people the essence of family and really
gives them the essence of like like a
road map to follow of like this is how
we create the community and when you
experience that there you can then take
that home and it feels so much more than
just like a thing you go go do it's like
a it's a return to a mindset that we've
forgotten return to even like a system
that we've forgotten like everything
being Money free and like how you you
you be kind to get your needs met you
rely on each other you give to get you
can't do that if it's everything's about
money or everything's about like
debauchery and and like just your
self-pleasure there is this constant
reminder of like oh I've got extra food
I'm going to go make something and then
just hand this out in my camp like
that's what's in instilled in that and I
think that's such a beautiful practice
this feels like this human
experiment in like so how Society could
operate can you share what your work is
like what you help people work through I
feel like it's so unique and I think
it's a good really like needed for this
point in time uh and so interesting so
could you please share that so at the
heartbeat of what I teach is I teach
primarily women how to use their body as
an instrument for something Beyond just
expression it's like an instrument of of
incarnation what you're incarnating as
your call but most people are walking
around very
habitually and when I'm with someone in
their body I'm really looking at what's
happening in the body that
is related to the mind the beliefs
around let's say love because a lot of
my work is around love I teach people
how to be artists with their body and
most people are walking around taking a
particular shape and for example if we
just put something to this there are
things we do with the body that
correlate to thing beliefs that we have
around love so let's say there is
a woman who was raised by a um like two
parents and and her dad was sick and she
grew up and she thought well my dad is
sick I have to car take and every time
she took care of her dad he would give
her more affection more love she felt
really needed in those moments and then
she grows up and she starts to take this
shape not just through you know size
weight all those things actually not at
all through those things it's through
energetics so she'll take the shape of
in order to be met in love I have to to
help I have to help I have to help I
have to find somebody who needs help and
so she takes a shape with her body of I
am she who will help in love and it's
not really serving her because she can
never find matches who will meet her she
finds Partners who need her and then she
doesn't know how to set boundaries and
the shape that she takes is constantly
like yes yes I'll help you yes I'll help
you so she's dating the same exact kind
of people She's Dating the the let's say
men who are holding the shape of I am so
worthy of being helped you know and and
God bless him I'm not saying anything is
wrong with his shape at all but maybe he
takes the shape of like I must be helped
I find the woman who helps me I am a
magnet for that so one of the primary
things that I help people find out is
what's the shape that you're taking and
look at your life that's probably what's
happening you're attracting these
situations where you're bored when
you're dating people because you don't
know how to like take a different shape
or you bring the creativity and you
bring the energy or you take the shape
of dissatisfaction and love and you just
keep getting these
instances so defining who do you want to
be in love and how do you embody her how
do you breathe like her how do you eat
like her how do you walk like through
the grocery store like her and how I do
this how I help people become artists
with their body a lot of times comes
down to creativity so I'll give these
spontaneous practices like all right
you're you're being a hum drum woman I
want you to go Sing Down the grocery
aisle I want you to open everybody in
the grocery store by singing like wear
pigtails I don't care be bright but just
sing and then get out of there but just
try to open the store or maybe I'll have
them do something like go to a cafe and
write a stranger a poem and then have
the waitress take it to them and then
you just sign it anonymously and all
these little creative things that help
them like break out of the habitual
pattern like break out of the like a
like I'm collapsing in in love and
instead begin to open in Love by
choosing to do these things that you're
opening people you're opening people
it's not just about what you want it's
about how you offer how you offer in
love because you have to have a reason
to take a new shape Beyond just I want
to find my husband I want to find a
person who entices me I want to be
enchanted what about becoming she who
enchants she who gushes like
Aphrodite's desire how can you become
this because it's the becoming of her
it's to give you way more than finding
him finding the partner that fits all
the things because even when you get him
you're going to be like but I'm still
dissatisfied I'm still bored I'm I still
need to help I still feel unlovable when
he's not asking me for help that's
because your body isn't transmitting
something yet you're still in the
habitual pattern
so down very so is it about being able
to shape shift all the time or is it
about finding your new shape like as in
birthing into like what you really want
to be and let's say maybe that can
evolve over time or we can sort of
alchemize things and evolve but but is
it about being able to shape shift or is
it taking a new
shape beautiful question and it's both
it's definitely both because you're
gonna have moments
where um you you're going to have
moments in your life where
shape-shifting is required particularly
again because I love to focus on
relationship you're going to find
somebody who you love and everything
feels really deep and beautiful and
there's chemistry and natural polarity
and then you start to feel that there's
this Kink there's something in your
connection that's either like stuck or
unspoken and in those moments if you're
really practicing being a shape shifter
as an art form you can slow down like a
priestess and ask what's the thing that
my relationship needs in this moment for
us to clear that Kink for us to drop the
veil and actually see what's what's
happening here to speak the unspoken or
to Delight the moment to shock the
moment you know when we get into these
fights sometimes it's two people who are
collapsing you know what the guy might
be like I don't know I don't know this
just keeps happening I don't know it's
my guy voice and then you know and then
she's gonna be like I don't know I don't
know I don't know and like there's two
people that are like I don't know and if
you're an artist of Love who's
practicing like reading the energetics
of the room you can see okay we need
[__] play right now I'm going to go
blast this Sam Cook song I'm Gonna grab
his hand and take him into the kitchen
and we're gonna dance even in mdle of
the fight even in the middle of fight
when you want to stringle them you just
feel this is what our moment needs or
sometimes there's a breaking open of the
heart
so that's one thing that there are these
opportunities everywhere you go to shift
shapes maybe you go into the post office
and you want to play with the one in you
who's
like
so
ferle you're just GNA go you're like I
everywhere I go I want to practice being
she who must be filled with a sea of
seamen I totally thought of the post
office too and I thought about like
where do I want to be y the post office
is the best place to do it you know why
would you do it anywhere else but you
know for the average person who's saving
those moments for a date like what would
it be like if you just played at a level
two out of 10 at a level two I'm just
gonna breathe she who is so so so
[__] fertile I'm just gonna breathe
her through my body on a level two and
then like see what happens and then you
go to a date that night and you're like
I'm going to toggle this I'm going to
toggle this to a five and then see how
he responds if he likes that or if he's
like leaning in or if he's starting to
talk about babies I don't know maybe
I'll bring it up to a level eight and
the thing I want to say here is that for
a lot of people listening to this the
first thought may be this is about okay
so if I'm becoming the transmission of
like fertile mother Gaia then I must be
talking about pregnancy right or must be
insinuating conversation it's not about
that at all this is a subtle energetic
where you just start to feel your belly
get a little more full and a little more
like pregnant in the breath and then you
let your shoulders drop and then you
send through your gaze whatever the
archetype is you're playing with just
the transmission through your eyes and
maybe you Adorn like this you Adorn like
this you you eat whatever you eat as her
it's like you're feeding the G goddess
the next day you may wake up and want to
be like a Viking Warrior you know and
like you've got the heat you've got the
fire and you stomp when you walk and you
make like particular guttural sounds
when you make love so you are a wild
card like you want all the flavors of
shaki you are the feminine and The
Feminine wants to know she can embody
the thousand of different flavors of her
and that's what it means to be a shape
shifter it means that you know you have
the thousands Infinity really flavors of
shaki archetypes characters Essences
textures flavors so
that within you as a practice you know
that you can do that for yourself to
bring those up but also because the
moment needs it because you realize your
partner is burdened by something and you
want to offer devotional wife energy you
want to nourish him in that way you want
to gift him that thing that he's always
wanted and you know how because you're
practicing bringing devotional wife into
your fingertips bringing devotional wife
into your gaze listening as her and then
you can you know it's not to say you
can't just be you but like what if this
is who you are you are the shape shifter
that's why this is an identity that like
goes so much further beyond what do I do
today or like do I like this guy or do I
not like this guy and like getting so
stuck in your head rather than feeling
who am I becoming and embodying and
transmitting for love itself beyond what
I want I've tried some of this stuff not
like it wasn't from an an certain
practice or something that it's just
like femininity is something that I have
had to really cultivate probably because
of Nature and nurture like being the job
that I had the kind of personality that
I am the double Aries that I am like
like I have a lot of like strong
masculine energy and so I've done it
before and so I've done this like as a
solo trial practice of like what if I
just
like embodied like sexy and like
sexuality and you don't actually have to
do anything is actually the thing your
body kind of like you might naturally
flow into some things this is what I've
found this is my experience but just by
thinking about it is transmitting a
frequency and it is like crazy the
response you get when you just sort of
embody the feeling of something and the
way that people uh react to you
afterwards and so I haven't done like
the shape-shifting thing I haven't gone
like oh man you're really pissing me off
but I guess it probably what do I need
right now like I I can't say that I've
gotten into that practice but I have
done a little bit of the first one and
like I would love to hear more about
like getting into to sort of the nuan of
um of doing it as well as maybe what's
really happening what's happening when
you when you put this feeling into your
body when you shape shift when you um
become this different energy and you're
you're a different shape like what's
what's happening why does it what what
changes your reality when you do that so
something I've been talking about a bit
recently is that we cannot really have a
conversation
about let's say the feminine the
feminine if we're not also having a
conversation about
our feminine lineage the more recent one
really like our our mother and the same
thing goes for the masculine but I'm
going to talk about the feminine here so
if we're talking about I want to have
feminine embodiment because I definitely
believe a lot of this a lot of these
teachings that I'm talking about it's
feminine embodiment work so if we're
going to get into this feminine
embodiment practice as so many are right
now it's just really a common practice
like I want to be in feminine embodiment
well one of the missing pieces that I
think we are we're losing sight of is
the feminine that we are wanting to
embrace is significantly impacted by
where we come from so for example and
and a lot of my work also relates with
childhood wounds like how can we aliz
how how can we alchemize childhood
wounds but if you would think about your
mother and you think about your
grandmother and your
great-grandmother oftentimes the hardest
qualities that we grew up with are in
our life and I'm not going to say that
they were passed down to us so if you
have a mother that has qualities like
codependency or narcissism or borderline
like fill-in the blank with any anything
that may you know be alive for somebody
body just because your parent had it
doesn't mean that you have it you know
it's in you but what I do believe is
that it was put on you so for example
let's say that there's a mother that
gives her love and then pulls it away
and gives her love and then pulls it
away you never really know can I trust
the love that's coming to me is going to
stay as a kid you don't know then it
gets ripped away from you and that push
and pull of love can be put on a child
and that creates a response in them
to push and pull from love because
they're so afraid that love is going to
push and pull that they become the very
thing that they're like I hate that I
don't want any of that in my life but
they accidentally become it because it
was put on them so when we look at these
patterns of things that were put on us
as as children particularly as women who
are trying to open our hearts and trying
to embody love and we also need to look
at what were the things that were put on
us and I I find that this is really
challenging for a lot of women when they
start
to just flirt with the idea that they
may have a quality that their
grandmother had or that their mother had
that it's the worst quality ever and to
acknowledge that that is within you
because when we talk
about you know we see on Instagram these
little quotes that are like the karma
and my family ends with me because I'm
trying to stop it like trauma passes
down until someone chooses to stop it
right so we see things like
this actually acknowledging that you
have your father's narcissism qualities
acknowledging that you have your parents
like avoidant Tendencies and scared of
Love really owning that can be death
defying because that's the very thing
You' grown up to really hate and I find
this to be a it's outstanding invitation
for people to be able to
humanize their parent like I even have
with my clients I tell them you know
some of my students will be like oh my
yeah my my narcissistic mother and I
give them the practice you are you can't
say my narcissistic mother anymore you
have to say my mother and see what that
feels like not to include that label
that's really challenging it's really
painful for a lot of people because that
label makes sense for them it makes
sense of their story it make that
context they want to take it like a
backpack everywhere they go this is my
mother and it creates narcissistic
Tendencies because if you're so afraid
that everyone is like that you're
constantly thinking about yourself and
you're afraid that everyone's out to get
you and everyone's going to take
advantage of you and then you create the
very thing that you're trying to warn
everybody against and so I'm trying to
help help everyone that I can to
neutralize these these ways that we
point the finger and say you're this and
you're this and you're this and instead
say
I am shapeshifting I have this in me and
I also have the opportunity to transmute
it not transcend it we don't need to get
rid of anything the last thing that we
need is to like find a way to like
disassociate from things that are here
we need to root even deeper instead of
transcending so
alchemizing when you when we're looking
at the fabric of this work when you are
able to really
like integrate these components and
these pieces of
yourself you become a safer person the
world feels safer you know when people
are like I don't feel safe to blah blah
blah it's normally because you're just
not allowing yourself to feel so by
avoiding these these qualities in others
or pointing the finger you actually are
less safe because you're severing from
something that might very well be alive
in you and then
art is the way we play with it so I you
know very specifically for myself I um
had I had something like that with my
mother of
a um kind of like a I love you like like
with me it was like I love you go away I
love you go away kind of that experience
and because that's so that was so in my
body to expect that from people that I
would have almost like these two sides
of me like like the one that felt deeply
open and and like safe to love my
innocence innocence my like love is pure
I can love like see all of me and then
see more of me and I'm letting you in
and then the part of me that was like
okay no no no never mind never mind and
of ice Queeny I have an ice quean side
that like will stop feeling because of
my childhood Ood experiences like I
never had privacy as a kid I barely had
a front like a bedroom door as a kid
especially whenever I was in trouble so
they would always you know one parent
then the next parent then the next and
like kind of berate me with like so I
would learn how to retreat very far back
the shape I took was I'm not here just
I'm not here I don't care um I'm numb
like I was taking the shape and lo and
behold I was like older I would attract
people that were very explosive and
fiery because I was taking this shape of
like you can't penetrate me so I would
attract people that were like I'm
[__] gonna penetrate your energetic
field if it's the last thing I do so
just like these shapes we were taking
and in my in my relationship one of the
things that was a brutal piece of
feedback that I was able to over time
like take in was the the truth that I
had these two sides the loving open one
and then the ice queen one and at first
I was like uhuh nope and you weren't
aware this was not a this was not a
conscious awareness you kind of you know
only when you were shown it could you
see it the piece about the ice queen was
I I knew that but the the the way that
it was phrased to me like towards the
end of like you have these two sides and
it sounds like it comes from your
lineage your mother like that was like
what no I'm the victim here I'm the
victim and then that being able to like
really absorb that and really take that
in I began to think okay how do I create
art out of this particular thing these
two different sides and you know the
what came to me was the the siren
archetype these mermaids that like
seeing with beautiful voices and then
you know the the sailors hear the these
little ocean nymphs singing and then
they plunge to their death into the
ocean they dive into the water and it's
like sorcery instead of pushing this
away how do I bring this in in a way
where I own it and I fully touch it and
I create art with it and so when I talk
about art these are things that you can
do with your beloved for a sexual
evening where like the siren is [__]
and like you get to play with these two
different sides of like luring him in
and hissing him and showing and in fully
these two sides and there's a beautiful
quote I forget who says it but whatever
you touch F dissolves and so by acting
out these these sacred theater pieces
particularly with a beloved because
that's very vulnerable to really feel
like invoking those those two different
flavors or let's take narcissism let's
take any quality we deem negative if you
feel into like what's whatever is the
most narcissistic character person you
can think of and you really don't even
need a character you can really just
feel that quality of me me me and what
have you just touched that for an
evening where it was just me me me me me
and you got kind of like grotesque with
it not pretty Valley Girl M me me but
like what shape does does the entity of
narcissism take is it like a black like
just gurgling bottom pit of goo or is it
like is it like a succubus or is it what
does it do I don't know but you can
allow yourself to fully take that shape
and be witnessed by it and have your own
sacred theater performance or like
create reals and videos out of it which
is something that I've I've done so
by taking this negatively deemed quality
and sort of bringing it in and becoming
it and are you talking about and it
might be all these things the energetics
of it so it's not like necessarily I go
put an outfit on or is it also that or
is it that is it saying like do you do
you not you energetically embody it as
well as act it out and then why would
you do that what is the point of fully
getting into it that you're trying to
assist because assuming you don't
necessarily want that quality but it's
there so like acting it out feels like
am I being it m yeah well you already
are that's the
thing that's the thing most people don't
realize it's like you're more of it now
than you will be after you actually
choose to be in it so I'll give an
example here of like two I know these
Concepts when we're talking about being
an artist of Love sometimes concepts are
like ah they're way up here bring it
down so one of the things that I'll say
is I'm a teacher of sacred theater so
this would be what I would really
recommend for anybody that wants to do
this is that you think and you you feel
into this energy that we're talking
about whatever it may be this the thing
you don't want to feel the quality you
don't want to observe the quality you
don't want to have inside your body and
you give yourself a practice where you
perform as that costumes or office it
doesn't matter that that is less
important though it can be fun you know
can be fun to like put on your uh mortia
Garb if you're going into something
that's a little dark if you have that
like very particular black outfit or you
want to put on trash bag whatever just
you can like get into character even
more but it's more so about taking the
physical shape so I I've done at all my
events we do uh one last evening of big
sacred theater performances and I give
everybody something different so like I
had a woman that was constantly afraid
everybody was projecting on her like I'm
not going to take your feedback and of
course it was with me a lot because I'm
the teacher and so that's gonna be the
first person that's like I'm not taking
your feedback you know but so funny
because she's in my program wanting it
and then she gets it and she puts it
away and the thing is she's projecting
so she is the thing she's so afraid of
and so like for her the assignment I'd
give her is I want you to bring
projections to Broadway and do an entire
sacred theater performance bringing the
show projections to Broadway a five
minute piece and then they go off and
then they decide what they're going to
do with that I had a woman perform a um
like sacrifice on the part of herself
that was afraid of love and she did this
theatrical piece of like you know
stabbing herself and ketchup flying and
she like fully
enacted so when we're talking about
sacred theater we're talking about
enactment and ritual enactment is how we
know know as a nosis like deep body
knowing we are in a world where we're
talking we're doing therapy and we're
talking and we're just being so in our
heads the body never actually gets to
learn the story the memory the belief so
when we enact which is like I mean
theater goes back to the 4th century
when there's dianis is theater and
everyone was creating these ritual
enactments to remember the cosmos
like actually becoming thesbian of the
cosmos to remember how the tides turn
ritual enactment theater is one of the
oldest religions one of the oldest ways
that we have ever known like by
performing being the fox we know the fox
we know the seasons that the fox
understands we can under the
shape-shifting it's how we understand
the world so when we can find fun and
playful ways to perform your siren or
perform your sacrifice or I had a woman
once um grieve a flower as it died and
like do a poem as she peeled the petals
off and like really and like really
enact her own grief that she wasn't
touching and we these kind of sacred
theater performances can be fun they can
be funny they normally are when we enact
when we let our body to take the shape
of the projection on Broadway when we
own the thing loud and proud or when we
shrivel up and we become the entity of
remorse or or sorrow that hasn't been
felt that's when we finally set it free
it's a part of you it takes its power
away because it's integrated because
it's like oh this this is a part of the
entire Cosmos of course this is a part
of me and any any of that shame starts
to get it's kind of like if you have
like a taboo kind of fantasy like when
you enact things things normally they go
away like it just doesn't hold as much
power so what happens in your world is
that you're actually able to allow love
in on a much deeper level because you're
not afraid everyone's trying to take
advantage of you because you've enacted
the part of you that is fear
mongering if you're afraid everyone's
trying to take from you go enact her
what does she look like what is the I
can't trust you I can't trust you I
can't trust you like the frenetic could
you give her a voice voice and show us
in your body what does it look like when
you're really unable to trust anybody
and then go a little deeper and then go
a little deeper and then go a little
deeper and and touch that deeper most
point you can access
stop pause breathe and feel the space
that's available because it's those
energies that you're carrying around
with you all day long it takes a
tremendous amount of energy it's a doubt
everybody is telling the truth and to
worry everyone's wanting to take
advantage of you and that's why you're
probably bringing it into your life over
and over and over you keep getting these
experiences where people aren't
trustworthy because you're taking the
shape of I don't trust anybody it's just
a perfect match when you are familiar
with this part of yourself whatever the
energy is you stop carrying around this
magnetic field that's going to be a
match for those
experiences and your nervous system
starts to decompress and you start to
have so much more space to breathe and
experience and actually let life in
you reduce the charge because
essentially you stop judging it so much
and maybe even found find some amount of
respect like maybe you get into this
some kind of archetype or some kind
of shape of something nasty and you're
like that was kind of fun
and so then you kind of go oh okay like
I'm not scared of that anymore and so
you like you sort of you take away the
charge because you stop judging and
fearing it which actually pulls it in
because you're thinking about it and
essentially you stop thinking about it
yeah when you said that it it feels like
it's no longer a a charge it's actually
more like a choice like now in your
repertoire that you can play with any of
these things and there's no
there's no uh charge around it you know
like I have a friend she was talking the
other day about somebody called her like
um princessy and I was thinking you know
that you that could activate you because
you're like a refined mature woman and
if someone says something like that
because that person who said that was
clearly going through their own stuff
clearly that person who would say your
princessy has a belief that you need to
work hard in order to be loved and they
judge people who aren't working hard to
be we love you know you could see these
patterns so easily but for her my friend
it was like ouch that hurt and I was
thinking like what a fun Shadow to be
like yeah I am a princess like I love
being a princess life being a princess
is so good and going on this sacred
theater princess rant of like show what
it's like to just [__] be a princess
and not saying for her that that would
do the magic trick but this is what
we're talking about these things that
like I'm not princess or like whatever
someone calls you kind of like stirr in
your mind when you can own it you could
just claim it and bring it in and make
art out of it and have fun with it and
have a princess day and like what can
you do to
totally bring in the very thing that
you're saying no I'm not so that you can
play with it so when people make these
comments you're like yeah I love being a
princess what's next and and that charge
is gone it takes time it takes a lot of
time to really like sift through the
things that are active for us and find
ways to create art out of them and a lot
of these things I'm talking about are
things we do for ourselves but then
there's like how do you gift your
princess how do you gift the very
thing like if you think you're too
much you can do all the sacred theater
like to support yourself through that
but then if you think too much how do
you alchemize that belief of too
muchness and offer your too muchness how
do you offer it as a gift to open a
space to bring so much love to someone
who needs it to bring so bring too much
of whatever just playing with your your
biggest fear as your biggest gift if you
embrace your biggest fear of who you
think you are and alchemize it into your
biggest gift you'll fine that you have
erotic flavors you didn't know that you
had you had you have friendship
qualities you didn't know you could
bring to the table you have values that
a king is g to die for when you learn
how to embrace it rather than wasting
all this energy hating yourself for
something that's like perfectly on time
and meant to be in your body I think I
want to talk a little bit about
masculine feminine just it's a sort of
an area that fascinates me based on my
own sort of life and you know I I get
very curious about the needs and wants
and if there are actually them or not um
so like what is c can you describe
feminine energy can you describe
masculine energy and the way that I
describe it the feminine is everything
that is energy it is energy it's the
Stars it's the volcano it's the
personality it's the quirks and The
Kinks it's all of the Leafs it's the
rivers it's just anything that's pulsing
and
Alive we can look at this in many
different planes we can look at this in
nature you know we can look at this in
our body we have the physical body then
we have everything happening inside of
it we have the heartbeat we have the
moving blood we have the
personality we can look at this in
regards to energetics so feminine would
be and in this moment right now I am
because I'm talking we'll switch polls
in a minute then you'll be talking and
then I'll be listening and I'll be still
so in these micro moments this is
alive and then we have people we have
people so we have the people who are
more on the feminine scale so these
people would be those who are more
energetic
more red versus blue more prone to um
highs and lows and they want love and
they they grow through
praise people oscillate between these
two poles and like some people are
primarily one more than the other I'm
primarily a feminine being I want all
the love I want all the connection I
want every love story to end with a
happy ending doesn't matter what the
story is I want it to end happy
everybody gets married they live forever
I don't want anybody to die just like
love and then we have the masculine and
if the stars are the feminine then the
masculine is like the one of my teacher
calls it the Indigo Dome it's the blue
indigo Dome that's holding everything
it's
nothingness so the masculine is
consciousness whereas the feminine is
all the things life masculine would be
more closely related to death it's
endings it's nothingness so I believe
every person has a has a very very very
um distinct Soul that's
untouchable right so we come into this
world and we have parents and upbringing
and we gain all these pieces of our
personality but I think at the very very
very very heart of each individual there
is a Consciousness that's the same and
we build upon that and that
Consciousness the thing that's never
shifted that's the masculine it's like
the OG yeah we look at nature it's it's
much more like the desert it's the
emptiness it's the openness whereas
kwaii and the jungle would be the
feminine it's Lush and alive and
everything wants to eat you the
masculine is emptying out it's vast pure
potentiality too in The Emptiness so
pure potentiality for the feminine so a
masculine is always Holden and a
feminine comes in and she she like
washes and waves and and brings up and
and and extends the masculine job
primarily is to deepen moments to deepen
moments with the space that's there and
when we look at
people oftentimes Whoever has the most
masculine is the one who is more still
more grounded when the struggle for a
lot of masculine prone beings is that
they're always looking for freedom
because they want to rest in the
infinite Bliss of nothingness so this
this is something we can see often with
men who are you know avoidant like I'm
just looking for Peace So if I just
leave this relationship or if I just go
live in the mountains or if I just buy
enough Bitcoin or if I just drink enough
beers or if I just ejaculate enough then
rest whereas the feminine is like more
more more I want I want like big laish
dinners and I want more love and more
orgasms and we get filled by more
so the masculine is more so looking for
how do I this isn't all of us I'm saying
like men and women here just to really
anchor it into the body but everybody
has all of this I have a masculine
that's like if I just you know go go
away for a bit of time and and finally
find peace then I'll be happy you know
we have parts of ourselves but in its
pure Essence it's it's the container
it's time and it's space this this is um
one of my teachers his name is Josh re
and he is just a Storyteller who is
impeccable and he is very familiar with
sounds and and like vocal traditions
where we invoke the feminine and the ma
masculine or in another way words we can
say the goddess and the gods through
sound and if we're talking about
feminine masculine here like we just
talked about nature we talked about the
body we talked about energetics there's
also sound so if we make a sound like
like a
a it's like open a the god
Shiva
Krishna
Brahma that sound is the masculine and
it's actually the deepest sound that the
body can make is a a and then we can
also think about what's the feminine
sound what's the sound we make that
invokes life and energy and it's like
e e bumblebee like it's Buzzy it's
energetic bunny shaki
Lakshmi um K like any goddesses we think
of have not all of them or Aphrodite I
guess a lot of them do it has this e
sound and and this is not accident it's
not accident that when we say these
names we are invoking the actual my damn
name it that's it it's my damn name it's
a damn
name there's like it's like there's
truth to it you know but I don't Maline
Maline yeah I like it Maline
Dano have a mix in there uh but yeah so
there's also sound like nature knows
what it's doing and and I think also the
the vas do and all of the beautiful
Traditions that were before our time
many many many many moons ago starting
this of like discovering oh when we say
a we feel that Indigo dome in the body a
we feel the container we feel the depth
this deep sound and then when we say e
the brain gets a little and our body
feels stimulated and we can feel the
goddess we can feel
shaki coming about so I just wanted to
add that because I think it's it's
that's very tangible for people to if
you need to embrace a little more one or
the other say those sounds go to the
bathroom go outside Go sing to a
tree in the
mirror what is it that helps a man get
into his masculine and a feminine get
into her
feminine
well in the body it it's very easy and
if we're just looking at body energetics
we have lifestyle energetics we have
like shapes that we take
we have creativity we have practices but
just in the body if a man wants to
embrace more of his masculine the rule
of thumb is you enter more grounded
Consciousness like as a man or you're
saying for the woman to help the man or
the feminine to help the man the man no
so I'm just looking at if a if a man
wants to be more that's a question right
if a man wants to be more in his
masculine or what was the question yeah
yeah and also what someone what the
other person can do to help it like what
what kind of container do I need to
provide so that he can be in his
masculine what kind of container does he
need to provide for me to feel
comfortable to be in my
feminine so what what I'll first say is
that you're not asking this but I'm just
for everyone listening is that I do get
this question often of like how do I get
my man to be mourn as masculine and
there's a difference between what you're
asking which is being the embodiment
being like the example Prov like taking
the transmission that you believe will
open up an opportunity for them versus
my man's not doing what I want him to do
he's not masculine enough my friend's
partner is you know like then we start
projection projecting and contorting and
that's not the healthiest way to support
people to get into these polls so there
is a level of unattaching while also
there is a level of um offering that we
can do so again for the for anyone who
wants to be in the masculine I'll just
say anyone that wants
that they would be embodying grounded
Consciousness
so if a person is left right up down
here there all the air quality what
they're going to need to do is practice
Stillness practice meditating watch how
your body wants to do this and practice
grounding for the feminine if you are
someone that for women who want to be in
the feminine if you're prone to being
really self-sufficient really still
really grounded you practice the
opposite you practice reveling in
pleasure you practice exploring like
like facial expressions like what the
[__] or like like what would it be like
to animate your body when you're not so
used to animating your body and maybe
you find pleasure and maybe you
experiment with just like a like more
aliveness in your sacred rage you just
feel what it's like to inhabit all of
your body and then reveal that through
the body now if we're looking at how do
we help our partner oftentimes it's the
same thing if you want your partner to
embrace more of their masculine you're
going to have to do your practice of
being in your feminine because that is
what polarizes a moment everyone has
masculine feminine but in order to
create
polarity and for both of you to deepen
you have to soften one of your
poles so if you want your partner to be
more in the masculine you have to soften
your masculine for a bit of time like as
a as a
practice I'm gonna soften the part of me
who is still and I'm gonna amplify the
part of me that is she who gushes with
volcanic pleasure whatever transmission
you want to play with and then you bring
that to them you bring that to them with
your whatever invitation you want to
make maybe you like actually create a
Sacred Space in the bedroom and you want
to gift them this part of you and then
if you notice them start to move and
Sway and they're like getting into the
feminine um you can you can praise them
into Stillness like I I want you to sit
here and I'm going to like I'm going to
wash your feet as a king or I'm going to
I want to dance for you will you sit
here and just breathe with me kind of
giving them some subtle cues of what
would feel good so if you want them to
be still more like give them that cue
and then when they do it let them know
you like it sometimes people don't then
do that and then how are they going to
know so then then you like are like oh
it feels it feels so good when you sit
like like that you're just like touching
your body and like revealing to them how
good that feels when they do that and
then in life just in life when when you
notice that they're they're holding you
in a kind of way that feels profound
they're um I had something happen
yesterday where my partner had to take
me to the ER very unexpected yeah very
all all is well but he like went into
action and like get in the car we're
going to the Y where I was like I'm
going to be fine
and he just like filled out all this
paperwork and was just very focused and
for me I was like oh this feels so good
like thank you for giving me this part
of you that is like Daddy like this part
of your daddy feels so good and I just
worshiped this part and same thing when
you know there was a dog that was about
to attack my dog and he like jumped in
front and I was like like oh my God feel
so good when you just jumped in front
and protected me and Ollie like let like
getting into a pattern of letting them
know when they do something
that like yeah because if they don't
know they don't know so so so many
people are really focused on when
they're not doing it and not really
noticing when they are doing it so
getting in a pattern of saying that
feels amazing like it's so sexy whenever
you are embodying that level of King and
I I love even like spending a delicious
night in bed where you're honoring that
part of their King and let them know I'm
honoring the part of you that holds me
I'm honoring the part of you that
cherishes me I'm honoring the part of
you that claims me like let him know the
things that feel good yeah praising and
and also let there's also like so much
room for just sitting down and being
like hey baby I love when you do this
but these are some of the places where
my trust kind of falters with you and if
you were more intentional with timing
and if you were more da and if you were
more da like this would help me lean in
even more and make me trust you even
more like you're always welcome to just
share those things in a loving container
where they can receive it sounds to me
like without trying essentially what the
masculine needs to feel is femininity
and softness and playful and happy and
sexual and sensual to be in his
masculine and then the
feminine needs to feel a man that is
steady constant quiet almost and just
stoic and like holding space and has got
them and they're there for their any
need and that will help a woman feel
like she can be in her feminine is that
am I or describing them correct I yeah I
would say that's like some of the basic
principles I really want to say this
that um the feminine is anything that's
energy so bring your [__] ferocity
like bring your openhearted pain bring
your bring it yeah bring it make it
Amplified the the invitation is to do it
with a heart with an open heart because
like I'm definitely not I am definitely
not like sweet and happy and pretty and
these things like a lot of the time a
lot of the time I'm just like I'm loud
and I'm like affected and I'm like [__]
and I'm like I have a
tantrum the the feminine is anything is
energy
so you bring any of that but the thing
is bringing it with an open heart
because sometimes woman will be like I
want a man who will hold all of me well
that's a that's a is it all of you with
an open heart or do you want someone
that will hold all of you all of your
your anger sharply because not many
people will do that but you can learn
how to like bring your anger and your
anguish with an open heart like
connected to your heart like like I love
love you like show the [__] up I love
you like that kind of anger is an
invitation so you can bring all of that
and for the masculine too like I'm
definitely not interested in a man who
is just stoic because then I'm like I
want to [__] feel you like I want to
feel you like where is your Warrior
connected to your masculine where is
your fighter your your sexy ass magician
like give me all that so for the for the
masculine the basic principle is
consciousness and most women want to
feel you they want to feel your
aliveness they want to feel your called
Drogo so if you're just like I am
practicing Consciousness like she'll
probably get really annoyed so bring
flavors of the Consciousness like bring
your dianis bring your king bring your
daddy bring your Warrior that just got
back from Battle bring all those flavors
of him because we want all of those the
principles are are made to be built upon
they're made to be innovated with I
think people get really stuck in like
I'm feminine so I'm supposed to be this
way and they're missing the depth of
what's possible of that pole and I think
men same with men it's like by just
practice being still maybe she'll have
more energy and it's not often the case
like we want men to feel pleasure we
want the the man to feel alive and have
personality and there are the moments
where he like will he has the power with
his depth to ground a moment to bring
that ferocity in it for us to like like
say come over here like really
powerfully and command but it's not that
you're empty it's that you're like full
of command you talked about
communication and like there's times to
communicate things and it brings me to a
topic that I feel like probably plagues
many many people is the communication of
sexual wants and
desires and I'm curious how couples get
to a place where they can talk about
that and where they can open that up and
explore and learn to satisfy and you
know I I wonder how much of porn and
various different things sort of Falls
underneath this sort of like messy
messiness of not being clear and having
desires that are unmet or things that
feel like maybe they're too taboo for a
relationship so can you speak to how
people can open that up with
non-judgment the first thing is create a
culture of it create a culture of this
being a common thing you visit and I
mean the question is how do you do that
if you're not comfortable with it so
it's hard to just skip to a culture and
if you adopt the mind mindset that this
is what we do this is what we do this is
this is now just what we do it becomes a
lot less scary than like what's the
first time we're ever going to do it
just embracing like this is what we do
and for now you can have a check-in
every
Sunday every Sunday there is a routine
check-in so it's less intimidating of I
have to bring this forward it's just
Sunday it's that's the day that's the
day so Sunday you know at dinner youall
are going to have your here's what I'm
loving and here's how want to play even
more and that's your time to share
that's your feedback time and there are
some agreements that are of course
really supportive like not being a no
like to to everything or like trying to
be yes ands like yes I like thata idea
and I want to do these things before we
go to that place or yes I like that idea
and I need these things to be you know
involved as well instead of the no
because I'm not saying you can't be a no
to things of course you
can but if you want to create a culture
where these things are safe to share
having a yes and mindset would really
allow for each person to feel heard and
not shamed or shut down in their desires
because no can be really kind of like
it's the end of all
possibility and again sometimes no is
the most important thing for you to
claim and sometimes there's a lot more
creativity that is allowed when you're
you just adopt like yes and and you add
to it what else do you need it's like
this is like an improv practice where
you always end a sentence with and so
that the conversation and the
possibility keeps going forward what if
we did this in our relationship where
you have this thing that you're Desiring
and you bring it and your partner's
automatic response is going to be yes
and this is how I would like how I would
need to shift it in order to be a full
yes this is what I would long to be this
is the the thing that I would you know
shift with it and and then of course
it's you know commit to the theater
commit to the theater so if you're
wanting to play with some
specific archetype or have a Kind of
Night commit to the theater like set up
the room turn your phone on do not
disturb like make a make a very Sacred
Space bless the room set a prayer go
deep deep but there are so many ways
that couples are just habitually making
love or habitually having sex without
actually dropping the veil and seeing
like
do we need to enact something that needs
to be brought into the light so that we
can make love soul to soul is there
something that needs to be said or
something that needs to be expressed or
something that needs to be done and
also encouraging
couples to focus on when you have these
things that you want to explore sexually
what's the texture that it's giving you
not just the thing because you can do
the thing you can act out whatever
scenario or roleplay you want but what's
the texture you want to feel full that's
the thing for a lot of women it's just
like fill everything I want to feel so
full I obliterate and explode and like
ah I feel like I die and it's great like
if you're asking for a particular kind
of role play you're just
full what's that nutrient that you're
craving because that's something you can
do all day long it's not just in a scene
this is something you can play with in
your whole life like we were talking
about at the beginning like that or you
know presenting this desire through your
eyes to your partner on these subtle
levels I think
maybe you know maybe to just kind of
wrap it up with you know one of the
things that kind of got me to the place
where I was like like I really wanted to
talk to you was just your deep sharing
of you know how relationship has broken
you and essentially built you back up
and heartbreak is something that I don't
you know if anybody has escaped it like
it's probably just on its way it's kind
of not I feel like a matter of if but
when for for everyone at some point in
time so you know what was that lesson
that you learned from that through being
in a deep relationship to coming apart
and then coming back together again like
a year later without probably any
intention you had no idea right and how
does that happen and and what did you
learn and how are you different now that
breakup for me was one of the most
brutal things I've ever
experienced and you know really what I
experienced with with that was that in
that iteration of that relationship
because who I broke up with is now my
partner and we've gotten back together
and he's my everything and our
relationship is wildly different than it
was before like the the first iteration
we're we have a completely different
relationship from that craving process
we both went on it's incredible but that
first experience what I really learned
in retrospect is that I put my beloved
in a role I projected on him our whole
relationship and basically I put him in
a role and then I punished him for it I
made us I made us you know I mean some
some of this is valid some of it is like
did happen they were like you know he's
much older than me and there was like
some dynamics that were at play but I
kind of put him in in a role of like if
we were to say that I was struggling
with a power Dynamic I put him in that
role where he had more
power I kind of put him there where I I
I he didn't ask for that you know there
there were some like things that were in
a relationship but he didn't ask to be
put there and I would kind of cower the
shape I would take would to cow would be
to cow to prove this story that I would
that there's a power Dynamic but I was
doing it and and then I I kind of blame
him and be like look what you're doing
but I put him there I put me where I put
me you know and I didn't see that at the
time and then when we were when we were
breaking up I held on to that story
Tighter and Tighter of like this was a
power and then when there was nothing
left I could punish him
for and you know all my like upsetness
kind of started to dwindle like at him I
just had to sit with myself and that's
when the real grieving started and
falling apart and questioning everything
and it was really connected to my mother
connected to my father connected to God
it was so much more than just him but I
let myself kind of go crazy like I I
felt this crazy making process with that
breakup where I just felt so alone and
no one understood me enough and I had
like rules with my friends that I didn't
want them to go to parties that he was
at and like just trying to control
everything I could
until I realized that the story I was
holding on to about the power or
whatever it was at the time it wasn't
giving me the thing I wanted and and it
wasn't until he had moved on that I
finally
just access the part of myself that
loved him for free without him needing
to be that role and that's when my like
actual like light side of the healing
began because no amount of hating him or
punishing him or pushing him away was
ever gonna give me the thing I wanted
never never made me feel any better and
it never did anything helpful at all and
it wasn't until I um like I reach I I
extended he didn't even know it that's
the thing is we can be mad and they're
not even they don't even know sometimes
right like it's just us to we're just
holding on to something exactly and it
wasn't until I extended an olive branch
to him and I just said it was like after
he' moved on and I said like I I just
want I just want to love you I I set you
free and I I love you and I've come to a
place to be able to love you through all
the hate I had and that's when I you
know I felt set free and and him too
that's when he was just like like
something shifted and then
life took its turns and it brought us
back together in the most unbelievable
ways but it wasn't until I was able to
learn how to love him without him being
mine that our our relationship never
would have stood a chance at least on my
end for as long as I I you know needed
him to to to like not be this person
that I made him out to be to constantly
prove himself in order to receive my
love we never would have made it but
once I finally got to a place where I
loved him like stand alone I loved him
without orienting to me I loved him
without being my boyfriend I just love
him like I send love to you you don't
have to be anything to me once I
accessed that we stood a beautiful
chance in love and it has shifted
everything in how we communicate and he
has his own stuff that he had to do like
in relationship to me but that was
really the core thing that I learned was
like loving somebody Beyond them being
yours and
that kind of karmic healing has led into
my relationship with my parents my
friends everything and it's one of the
biggest gifts that he ever could have
taught me is it safe to say it's like
loving someone without a
story yeah it's loving someone without a
story without a story without without
without having to prove a story you know
without the story or proving a story or
proving something wrong having to do a
job like just having their existence
mean anything to you even right like
yeah right like it's just a well maybe
that would be called unconditional love
yeah it's you know it's kind of like I
don't know if it if your human
relationship can ever be quite like a
pet except for probably kids I hope so
because she's so cute yeah you know you
you can never not [__] love your pet
it's like they can do anything and you
just like so much love and we can only
hope to have that with our partners
where we like that's like the gold star
is when you can give your partner that
kind of unconditional love when they do
those things just like you're you're
you're my my beloved little pet when you
can just love them in that way like that
is a beautiful form of relationship
Enlightenment could you have done it in
relationship or do you think it had to
be done separate meaning if someone's in
a tough spot how can they repair without
breaking up or in your situation was
that necessary and maybe it's necessary
for
others it yeah you know I'll never know
if we could have done that in
relationship that's the thing like I I
believe that we couldn't have because
losing him was such an important piece
for me in my very you know individual
Journey but maybe we could have maybe we
could have if we had moved out of where
we were and we came we were in LA and
now we're in Austin maybe if we got here
sooner we could have made it work maybe
if we if we did that therapy session
that I canceled last minute you know
maybe if we did that we could have who
knows but um um you know I think it's a
really important thing for people to
practice in relationship loving Beyond
them being yours like practice I wrote a
post once that I said practice letting
your partner die practice letting your
man die like let the version of him die
let imagine your relationship dies
practice grieving every single day your
iterations of your love and let your let
your man like die and be set free let
him be set free in the relationship if
you can do that in the
relationship then you don't have to go
through a big expensive year-long
breakup to learn that lesson and it
it'll still it won't be as probably
World shifting to like go like move out
and like go through the breakup process
but if you can practice in the
relationship learning to love them
Beyond them being yours I think there
you have a much stronger chance of
actually working through whatever is
happening in your dynamic because
we aren't each others you know we are we
are we can be in Devotion to each other
but we have to also allow each other to
find to go on our you know our paths and
and learning how to do that in
relationship I think is the Ultimate key
to the long-term game right right well I
was talking about this earlier that you
know from point A to point B sometimes
is a really long windy road and that's
still the quickest
way yeah okay well congratulations and
um thank you you for sharing all that I
learned so much and I've been asking
about masculine feminine stuff and all
this stuff for a long time so you really
did a nice job of articulating the
differences as well as um getting into
the nuances of energies and how powerful
they are thank you thank you that really
means a lot to me because I know these
definitions are like floating around all
over and it's like hard to really I feel
very fortunate to like cuz my my partner
is like a teacher of relationship
Dynamics and so we get we get to really
get into the nuances together of like
what are we bringing like how are we
meeting each other in in like quote
polarity because it's going be whatever
we're doing is going beyond what we're
reading in books like this is something
you know we're we're breaking some of
those quote rules and I think it's
important to realize we can do that well
we're putting that's just words and
feeling is so much more informational
words are just a book and it's so
limited and it's only the things on
paper I interviewed John um back in in
2020 he was one of my uh initial covid
lockdown interviews and I was like well
I guess I'll just do it sitting at the
house with a computer and I have never
stopped since oh I love that congrats
that's beautiful than that were born out
of that time oh man man well thank you
so much for today and um tell John I
said hi and thank you for sharing he
said hi too he said hi too don't me tell
tell that earlier so he says hello and
thank you so much for having me this has
been really beautiful I'll see you at
Burning Man next year yeah I'll see you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button